[Music]
no one is allowed to raise
any questions
about whether or not joe biden
got more votes than anyone anywhere ever
this guy
thanks for joining me i'm here uh
the fema directors on
uh
uh the theme of director chris well
she's on
and i'm here with uh
with my senior advisor and uh
boy who knows louisiana very very well
man
that guy joe biden who did who did not
campaign when he did campaign 18 people
showed up he's got his mask hanging off
his face he doesn't know where he is
he's forgetting people's names he's like
i'm here and i'm where oh and then he
calls this black advisor boy that was
that's that's just the cherry on top of
the sundae
and i'm here with hey boy what's your
name boy
i'm huh
and fema
it's fema why all right because is that
is it superstorm that's ah
huh
that guy
if you question
whether or not that guy got more votes
than anyone ever and beat donald trump
by the greatest number of votes ever
it was it was a landslide
then you're a terrorist you're
undermining our democracy if you raise
any questions about election laws not
being followed you're you're an
insurrectionist
undermining democracy i don't do people
buy that anymore joe biden just got in a
little bit of trouble it's not real
trouble it's like fake trouble on the
right it's among conservatives i bet
people on the left didn't even see this
clip but but joe biden was
discussing the superstorm he was
discussing the fema director and then he
referred to a senior advisor of his who
is black as boy he's a boy who knows
louisiana
and you're not supposed to call black
people boy
because this was uh
derogatory that way back in the day and
now people don't even really remember
that but
joe biden is a racist see that's that's
what we're supposed to say that's what
we're supposed to conclude from this no
you know what we're the first thing
we're supposed to say is
if a republican ever called a black
advisor boy oh gosh could you imagine if
the shoe were on the other foot could
you imagine the outrage but there's not
outrage because the left they're
hypocritical
okay
yeah you're right you're right yeah
you're right if a republican did that it
would be a big outrage and be on the
news and he'd be called a racist but joe
biden did it and so he's not called a
racist and so
so what so what
everybody knows that joe biden didn't
mean anything by it nobody thinks that
joe biden is
you know
a klansman or something
nobody believes it it's all just fake
by the way the libs
don't care when you call them racist
they don't the libs who actually do
favor
racial discrimination in the law the
libs who actually do think there ought
to be a racial caste system
the libs who if racism has any meaning
whatsoever anymore are racist they don't
care
but we do care
we conservatives do care
it's the worst thing you can be called
in america today
if you're a conservative at least you
could be ostracized you could lose your
job you could lose your reputation if
you're a racist
and so we really you know if a
republican actually said oh man this boy
man i love this boy see who are you
calling boy oh no i'm not a racist
please don't call me a racist i think we
got to stop
caring about that racism if it has any
meaning at all is uh hatred of people on
the basis of their race right so if
you're not that that's an offense
against human dignity so that's why it's
wrong and simple so if you're not doing
that then who cares if they call you a
racist or they i mean they called ronald
reagan and neo-nazi okay and george bush
and donald trump and they're going to do
it to ron desantis or ted cruz they've
already done it to ted cruz they're
doing it to josh hawley
they're going to do it to whoever is the
next guy
so
who cares
who cares i just i think we need to stop
wasting our breath on this stuff okay i
mean it's funny because i'm not talking
about it but i'm talking about it as a
political strategy i'm not i'm not
talking about it as though joe biden is
now the leader of the ku klux klan or
something like that because he's not
it's just it's a cheap political attack
no one really believes at least of all
the left they're the ones who invented
the attack
so just cut it out okay
you beautiful person i'm so glad that
you enjoyed that video if you wouldn't
mind leaving me a comment that would
make me feel very nice you know just
saying hey michael my sweater thank you
i like but also what i need you to do
is go to wherever you get your audio
podcasts
and subscribe to the michael knowles
show it could be apple podcast stitcher
spotify google play wherever head on
over there right now
take out the old phone
here i got i got mine
got a lot of people spying on me no
doubt go type in okay podcasts go type
in the
michael knowles show
subscribe so easy you can leave a
five-star review if you want we
appreciate it helps us get around a
little big tech censorship we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you